when Nick texted me in like 16 and slid
into my DMs and we started chatting I
was at the end of my last long
relationship for Nick so I didn't want
to engage as much at that time I was
also like 35 and it was 25. I really put
a stop on it Priyanka Chopra admits she
was hesitant to start a relationship
with hubby Nick Jonas I didn't know he
was the one while appearing on Dax
Shepard's armchair expert podcast she
revealed that their 10-year age Gap had
her unsure if they would work out I
judged the book by the cover yeah yeah I
think I want to settle down I've been
there done the like fun days that's a
boy toys I was like ready to get serious
and not realizing my husband is actually
a 70 year old man stuck in a 30 year
old's body but it turns out Priyanka
couldn't resist Nick's serenading skills
I think I fell in love with him the
first time I saw him in the studio Nick
has the most incredible sound amazing
tone and control and his false and he's
very Jazzy and R B the way he sings my
knees buckled
[Music]
worthless I never thought that I'd catch
this
how did you know that your fiance was
the one how did you know uh it was kind
of an instant thing new once we locked
in together that I had a partner for
life and a teammate so I can walk to the
good times and bad times with and that
was that was the key I'm blushing now
Nick and Priyanka got engaged in 2018
after only a few months of dating tying
the knot in December that same year I
think we we settled into our roles as
husband and wife like fairly quickly I
have a lot of faith in who my husband is
and I know I have a lot of faith in the
rock that he is for our family fast
forward to 2022 that family grew bigger
when the couple welcomed their first
child daughter multi-marie I think our
daughter is the best gift that we've
ever received
she's loved and surrounded by a lot of
people but when she needs just me that
feeling is amazing that's just a special
thing and you know I think as as parents
it's everything has a new meaning and
has even more meaning and the Bear's
little one was born via surrogate after
Priyanka made the decision to freeze her
eggs in her early 30s it gets so much
harder to get pregnant after 35. I
wanted to get to a certain place in my
career and I also hadn't met the person
I wanted to have children with yes or I
didn't see that you know that
anxiety-inducing it's something the
actress now encourages her friends to
consider if you can afford it I tell
people you save money to buy a car every
month do it for Christmas it's the best
gift you'll give yourself because you're
taking the power of your biological
clock
to my beautiful wife the greatest gift
and I love being a parent with you of
course now Nick and Brianca are loving
that parent life it is certainly
life-changing she's uh she's amazing
um brings me a lot of Joy all is good do
events like this get harder when you
have a little one at home or is multi
secretly backstage
no she's asleep
can you imagine
exactly no tonight's Daddy and Mommy's
night out
[Music]
thank you